it's not working
it's time now for one more thing Dana
all right
all right if you are watching you might
have been watching for 12 years it's our
12th anniversary on the five today and
we I have some donuts got 12 of these
but one cupcake for your birthday but we
got 12 donuts for the five and these
come from Broad Street Dough Company you
have to check them out on Instagram can
you get a picture these are gorgeous the
founder is named Dez there's two
locations in New Jersey and one in
Encinitas California it's a growing
company Dez is an amazing woman Fruit
Loops uh sharks watermelon M M's and
then some sort of Smurf thing over there
and anyway we love our viewers and we
really most must thank the producers of
this show who put up with us and we have
given you a hard time 12 years as long
as I ever worked somewhere I know same
here yeah 12 years for us anyway you
guys get out of here Greg it can end
like that
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now